[Music]
[Applause]
let's recap our guesses who you think
Chris Collinsworth picked to win the
Super Bowl Todd the Baltimore Raven all
right Satan Jets all right Marvin
Vikings Vikings Paulie Chargers all
right let's bring in Chris Collinsworth
NBC football night America joining us on
behalf of Pro Football Focus a new
fantasy punishment playoff contest that
we'll talk about here in a moment your
pick I said it was a
sort of a surprise
yes
and your pick is
the Bengals okay
there you go I I I it's time it's time
who's better who who's who's better at
this point in time than the Cincinnati
Bengals I've never picked them not once
in my entire career
I I think it's their year I think they
can do it I really do no concerns about
Joe burrow right now
uh well I might be more concerned if in
fact Joe Burrell were playing in the
preseason you know he hasn't played the
last three you know he had the he had
the knee thing he had the appendicitis
now he's got the calf so if all of a
sudden now he's playing in preseason
then
can't pick them right you can't you
can't go with that so yeah but I I have
no idea I you know who if if I really
had to go to Vegas yeah and go all right
you get one team you get one team
I would never pick anybody in the AFC I
I just witnessed too hard I I mean I I
can go up and down the list I can pick
10 teams out of the AFC and then you
come back and you go to the to the NFC
and you go all right do I like San
Francisco do I like Philly do I like
Dallas you know maybe who's the long
shot in there Seattle Minnesota you know
I don't know
go to Vegas and pick one today
I know me I'm not the favorites so
ordinarily I would say Philadelphia is
the favorite in the NFC I would go for
some odds I would probably go for Dallas
I help me understand the philosophy and
how it's changed in the preseason of
playing your starters playing your
quarterback you know Andy Reid had
Patrick Mahomes out there and then other
coaches don't want their starters to
come you know don't even dress so what
has changed in the philosophy of you
know Anthony Richardson with the Colts
like how how much do you play how much
do you not play
I mean well you'll remember Mark Levy
played nobody I mean nobody and they
were in the championship or the Super
Bowl almost every year so uh 17 games
there's a lot of games I mean it's just
a long time to just and and the worst
thing in the world is to leave somebody
out there and and uh in the preseason
but we went to Detroit for the the Lions
and the Giants that we could practice
you know where they put the two teams
and they practice twice and then they go
play in the games and
um
unfortunately that's become the better
route now for teams to get ready for the
season and so you're getting a lot of a
lot of the star player time that's going
into that
um I don't know how we can play
preseason games where you're not allowed
to touch the quarterback but it's
probably a good idea because then I
think they would play those guys a lot
um
but Andy Reid and these old school guys
they keep winning championships you know
I mean Andy is notorious for being the
hardest uh coach during the course of
preseason and yet here they are they're
playing Patrick Mahomes they're playing
Travis Kelsey and they keep winning
Super Bowls and you know Bill
Belichick's doing the same thing live
tackling during training camp open field
tackling anytime I bring up the idea of
maybe getting rid of preseason football
during the course of all right guys
let's just go down to one game or two
every one of these coaches say the same
thing they go crazy like there's no way
to evaluate these players
um would I play Patrick Mahomes during
the preseason and I I know I I I I just
wouldn't because you got to get through
it right you got to get a championship
game and uh you know but who am I to say
they've done pretty well in Kansas City
what's your position on starting a
rookie quarterback
Tony Dungey and I have this argument all
the time
um Tony is of the belief there's only
one way to learn how to play and that's
just to get thrown in there and you know
Peyton Manning and he threw up 18
interceptions his rookie year and he
didn't care and that's how you figure it
out
it is so hard right now when you think
about what we put these kids through
starting at the end of college football
season they go right into this intensive
training for the combine they go through
the whole draft process as soon as they
get drafted they ship them off to mini
camp they go in all summer and they're
trying to figure out what the Playbook
is and everybody in the media and blah
blah blah all that stuff you can imagine
Anthony Richardson's Year by the time
they get to the season and now you've
got to try and mix in with all these 30
year old men and Veterans and figure out
what you're doing and they're not
playing these simple little defenses
that they played in college anymore to
expect that those guys are going to come
in and win right away and be really good
right away is probably a little bit too
much physically and mentally at the end
of the day to try and try and win a
championship or try and just compete in
the National Football League I would
probably really sit them for a month let
them watch a veteran player get ready
deal with the media game plan memorize
all the names and the formations of the
plays and the audibles and watch him get
hit in the back the head by blitzes a
couple of times that he had never seen
on tape in the NFL
but that would be my philosophy he's
Chris Collinsworth football night in
America and just elected to the sports
broadcasting Hall of Fame
congratulations on that the fantasy
punishment playoff contest the winner
gets a VIP experience with Chris at a
Sunday night football game in a lifetime
subscription to PFF what do they need to
do
let's go to pff.com we've spent a lot of
money on our fantasy tools bro I tell
you what I've last year I finished next
to last I I barely escaped whatever the
punishment
Darren Waller let me down that was my
guy last year and so now you got to go
back right you know like it's like when
a receiver drops a pass and you got to
go back to them right when a guy misses
a three-pointer let's get him the ball
back in his hands and and get him going
again let's get him going so Darren
Waller I'm coming back again I'm gonna
I'm you know I'm not gonna let the fact
that the injuries blew my season last
year because I went high and hard after
him and it didn't work out explain to me
the difference of people talking about
the Cowboys because they know that gets
clicks it's the biggest fan base out
there and the reality of just how good
the Cowboys are so it you know in
relationship to how much coverage to how
good are they going to be uh how how
close are those two entities
okay
it's a really good question I mean it's
the historically it was they were really
great for a decade
and then they really weren't for a long
time and yet if NBC had their choice we
would do 17 Dallas Cowboys games right
I'm not kidding I know it doesn't even
matter what the record is it doesn't
matter they could be four and six they
did we would take okay you guys can pick
any game you want this we will take the
Dallas Cowboys it's insanity but it's
true they draw the ratings they they get
it done
um I I I think there's still an
intriguing team I mean we've got them on
opening night I mean every opening night
we want the Dallas Cowboys if we can get
them
um and but you know it's going to be an
interesting story I mean Mike McCarthy
you know Kellen Moore now calling the
plays that was a pretty good offense but
Dak Prescott through an extraordinary
number of interceptions last year in a
very limited amount of time they signed
Brandon Cooks this year they signed
stuff on Gilmore uh they've got probably
the best defensive player in football
perhaps and Micah Parsons right now who
apparently is terrorizing every single
thing going on in Cowboys Camp right now
um so yeah they're they're an intriguing
team I think they always will be uh
what's really interesting is we have Dak
Prescott coming up on a big contract
here I think next year he makes like 58
million dollars something like that uh
so a big year for him they get Zach
Martin back in Camp look at me I'm like
I can't do this with any other team you
can kind of go off the top you can't go
hey Cowboys you know I got them I know
what I know what's going on with them
and uh but it's craziness but the
Cowboys continue to be America's team
and that is no lie but you can go back
the Niners were there the Steelers were
there the Packers were there the Raiders
were there it felt like this was off our
childhood or maybe our dad's you know
childhood or upbringing where he kind of
this is the team we root for therefore
you root for and you have those you know
those fan bases that were born back in
the late 60s early 70s with these teams
you know the the thing that's so
interesting to me was that the Cowboys
were sort of uh America's team when they
had Tom Landry and they didn't seek out
publicity and they you know they were
they're sort of this you know this very
buttoned up kind of organization
now you get bring in Jerry Jones and
Jimmy Johnson and you and Michael Irvin
and they're the perfect team for social
media age
Generations right I mean Jerry's gonna
Jerry's gonna be out there all the time
you're gonna have Zach who's like this
perfectly situated guy he's great with
the media he's great in front of a
microphone you get so I don't know it's
like they they tended to just evolve and
to watch but I mean if you go like like
in sports you're in sports you know you
sit down at a table and you could be
with a politician and an actor and a you
know whatever famous people are out
there the conversation always starts
with the NFL like they turn to me and
they'll start asking me about their
favorite team or whatever I go I am
sitting at the most interesting table in
America I have a billion questions to
ask you guys and you always start with
the NFL it's insane how did that happen
how did it happen but the NFL just
literally took over the world and now
it's like all anybody wants to talk
about now you're gonna throw in fantasy
football and gambling and all the
different things that we have now and
it's just it's Non-Stop
how much jealousy is in the sport if I
and the reason why I bring this up Jerry
Jones and Jimmy Johnson there was
obviously jealousy that you know Jerry
wanted credit Jimmy got credit uh there
was a falling out Switzer comes in but I
don't know
how does that happen with players on the
same team with the quarterbacks getting
all the credit or you know the running
back or the white whatever that my
defensive player I don't know how
prevalent that is in the NFL
well
the higher up the latter you go the more
it is right I mean Howie Long used to
have a great saying you said you really
can't have more than one quarterback in
the room at any one time they you know
they suck all the oxygen out they they
you know you gotta have that quarterback
needs needs to have that and I think
that Jimmy and Jerry were a little bit
of that that same sort of person which
is you know it's hard to not think of
the Cowboys in that era and go how many
could they have won right what what
could have been if those two former
teammates and best friends could have
just sort of kept it together uh because
it really ended up it didn't help either
one of them honestly you know to to not
be with the other because they had they
had sort of everything going but yeah I
I think that and I bring that up with
Shaq and Kobe because I always said if
we would remember what they could have
been not what what they were because
they could have they could have reeled
off six in a row
yeah it's hard though I mean it really
is hard sometimes it happens at
broadcasting you know some some groups
some people don't end up meshing and
broadcasting because there's not enough
air time and there's not enough whatever
the case may be but yeah egos are
they're real I mean it's it's real but
if you can find the right Reggie whites
of the world right those China people
that just don't need it and can lead in
a dynamic way without sucking the oxygen
out of the room then you get magic out
of that we're going to Ireland tonight
we're going to watch Notre Dame Navy on
Saturdays you've been nice you've been
over there for the Notre Dame game in
Ireland right I did my son Austin played
in that game and uh it was for me it was
the perfect game it was we got to go and
and drink for two straight days with the
greatest people in the world I'm telling
you whatever you thought of Club in
Ireland might be like it's a hundred
times better than that from the minute
you walk in there you have you can't
tell the difference between a guy that
has was on Cheers and sitting on the
corner of that bar his entire life and
me the first time I walk in there they
are so warm so welcoming they love their
country they love the fact that you came
they can't believe that you came and are
sitting at the bar with you and it's not
like they knew me or they knew anything
about me it was just an American and you
know just come on it it is the coolest
place you don't need golf clubs you
don't need anything just go and hang out
in the pub and tell stories they don't
have to be true just make up anything
you want and and everybody will laugh at
your jokes and you're gonna have a blast
luckily for me the game was like Notre
Dame won like 50 to nothing that day too
so it was like we just sat back but but
you didn't walk out of the pub the way
Tom Brady walked off the boat after
winning a Super Bowl did you uh well you
know Tom has a little too much Purity in
his body that you know a little alcohol
can distort that whole thing I'm not I'm
not as pure so that you know a couple of
beards by the way if you have the
Bengals going to the Super Bowl who are
they playing who are they beating
uh again if I had to be honest I think
Philadelphia is the team to be okay you
know I mean Jalen hurts could have been
MVP in the Super Bowl last year despite
the fact they lost the game that was
that was what he did last year was
amazing to me the jump that he took from
your whatever was two to three and give
AJ Brown a little credit that was
something
yeah and it's weird it's almost like I
want to see another year of Jalen hurts
to truly believe it
um I I don't know if you ever get to
that point like you go
like I'm all in on this guy or like
Danny dimes I gotta see another year
there's a couple of guys I just go I
don't know and Jalen hurts even though
he should have been the MVP of the Super
Bowl I go I'd like to see one more year
here how about how about this what if
we're truly at that paradigm shift now
where if you don't have a quarterback
that can run right so forever we've been
you know Tom Brady and you know Troy
Aikman and Joe Montana no Joe can move
around but you know more the pocket
passer wins out there now the game is so
built around the quarterback we've
changed all the rules to favor the
quarterback you know you can hold and
pass protection you can't hit the wide
receivers you can't hit the quarterback
below the knees above the shoulders you
can't you you you're you gotta ease them
to the ground like the whole game is
built you can take the balls now that
used to come right out of the stinking
box and they had this slime on them so
nobody could throw them nobody could
catch them you didn't have gloves that
were sticky you didn't have any now the
whole game is built you can scuff up the
balls and you're allowed to do
everything possible so that these
quarterbacks can throw the ball so now
defense is how they doing all right now
they gotta they gotta drop back into
coverage we got to take away Tyree Kill
from Patrick Mahomes we gotta do all
these things so now running backs and
quarterbacks can run in a way that they
never could so if you don't have a
quarterback that can run with all these
guys sitting back in these two safety
looks and all the different things that
they have are you at such a disadvantage
now shoot if you can't run a quarterback
sneak the way that Jalen hurts ran the
quarterbacks are you at such a
disadvantage so I I'm beginning to
wonder are we seeing that shift now that
paradigm shift to where these
quarterbacks start to take over and
maybe Jalen just one of the early guys
in that process well Steve Young was on
a couple of weeks ago and he said we
won't have Dan Marino we won't have
Peyton Manning ever again at that
position
which is a pretty strong statement but
he said you know your the pocket passer
is becoming obsolete and I'll still take
Peyton Manning or tan Marino you know I
think you could win because if you think
about it what's the easiest way to
dominate a game one person sitting in
the middle of the field that can throw
at 53 and a third yards wide 60 yards
deep down the field that's a lot of real
estate to cover there's a lot of Acres
out there that you have to cover and if
this guy is good enough to stand in a
pocket and distribute it right left deep
short up down that's a lot to have to
cover but if you have to cover all that
stuff and the guy they can run four or
five I mean how do you do it and now you
got the RPO stuff so now the backside
linebacker can't even move because he's
got to cover the backside slant over
there because AJ Brown's gonna catch it
and run 60 yards down the field there's
it's hard to play defense right now in
this league one of our favorite websites
Pro Football Focus the fantasy
punishment playoff and the VIP
experience with Chris at Sunday Night
Football at a game and the fantasy
football tools have recently been
implemented as well great to talk to you
my best to the family thank you Chris
good talking to you Dan take a break
play the days up next